there's no shortage of remasters out  there but sometimes they show up as a  complete surprise I'm Tony and this  gamespot news update is out of this  world  remember Destroy All Humans on ps2 well  it's been remastered for ps4 and it's  available right now the game originally  released in 2005 so if you missed out  the first time you can now take control  of crypto and wreak havoc in the current  console generation our review of the  original release praises the game's  comedy so if that's something you're  into this remaster might be for you and  did I mention it's only 20 bucks Destroy  All Humans was published by THQ Nordic  and some of the studio's other ps2 games  are expected to re-release on ps4 soon  Red Faction one and two have already  been rated by the ESRB remastered games  definitely aren't going away so if you  want to keep up with all the titles  getting a new coat of paint you're  already in the right place